now we have the minutes of the meeting
held on Tuesday the 5th
December
[Music]
September we are happy that they are
correct
record
that's a s
explain benefit speakers on YouTube will
deal with
them thank you chair this is the
procedure for considering the business
this
afternoon the chair will introduce an
application then they ask the planning
offic officers to refer members to any
late comments or updates received since
the agenda was
issues these have been published on the
council's website and hard copies have
been s circulated to
you after this the chair will ask any
speakers to address the meeting there
are eight speakers and they will be
speaking on the two
applications speakers will have three
minutes to put forward their
views there will be a reminder given by
the clerk when 30 seconds
remain at the end of the 3 minutes
members of the committee will have an
opportunity to ask the speaker question
to clarify try any points they have
made after the speaker has addressed the
committee and answered any questions
then they will be allowed to remain in
the meeting but they will not be allowed
to participate
further from this
point the chair will then open for
questions
to debate by the
commination on
the votes will be taken by
ro fin members this meet is being liveed
reporting will on council's website that
others may choose to
copy I'm going to ask the planning
officers to tell us about any late
comments and give a brief represent
presentation showing any photos plans of
the site I will allow the officers to
complete the presentation
consequently members unless you have a
point of order that you feel cannot wait
could you please reserve these until any
questions about the process Until the
End right colleagues we have seven
speakers on the
application the first of which is Helen
Staten an objector they will have three
minutes to get over their points and
we'll be informed when 30 seconds
remains chair just before you go to the
speakers would you like me to introduce
the item and go through the presentation
that we have for yes please
adri thank you chair firstly I'd like to
refer members to the late comments
report that was sent out yesterday
afternoon and secondly chair officers
have received two further letters of
representation on the application late
yesterday afternoon and evening both
after the late comments report was
finalized and sent out to you they're
both from previous correspondents and
due to the length of the emails and the
fact we only have the two letters we
have on this occasion made them
available for all members in hard copy
for you to see inform form there
attached to the L representations report
that you have before you but have preed
the comments as follows the dwelling may
be altered to a house of multiple
occupation the highway comments are
incorrect in the report the comings and
goings will damage the road create noise
and be potentially dangerous there is
trespass issues already and the safety
of the Access Lane is questioned not
withstanding the comments made by the
council's policy officer the site is
unsuitable for the proposed use risk
assessments have been requested but none
have been
forthcoming the fact work has already
been undertaken should not affect the
decision to be made the noise abatement
plan will not work and has been shown
not to work as one res has already been
placed in the property the proposed use
will adversely affect the amenity of
neighbors the amount of time
permissible to speak is too
short the system is opaque rather than
[Music]
transparent already living at the
property and who will be held
responsible for the harm
caused in respect to the application
itself chair permission is sought to
convert a single dwelling to a premises
comprising three independent supported
living units the proper is located
within a primarily residential area and
has as its immediate neighbors three
other dwelling houses the application
sets out that the occupants of the three
units will be provided with ongoing
24-hour care certain Works to the curage
of the premises are to be undertaken to
modify the garden and create three car
parking
spaces chair officers have considered
the submitted information and the use to
which the converted property would be
put the level of care is noted and the
consequent activity that would be
associated with it and the occupation of
the premises as three individual units
officers have concluded share has set
out in the report that the overall level
of activity would have an adverse impact
on the character of the area the issue
of residential amenity has been raised
in representation there is the potential
for the outdoor space to be used in a
more intensive way than previously
however as the environmental health
officer has set out with appropriate
controls there is likely to be no
adverse impact on the immediate
residential Amendment of neighboring
properties from the use of the garden as
such officers have concluded in
accordance with that
advice overall chair has set out in the
report and in weighing all the matters
in the planning balance officers
recommend that the application is
refused on an Allied matter chair
members will note the reference in the
late submission of the applicant to the
equality Rights Act of
2010 further to the officer remarks that
are set out in the late commer report
chair I do want to advise members that
the ACT requires local planning
authorities to have regard to the need
to eliminate discrimination harassment
victimization and any other similar
conduct Advance equality of opportunity
between persons who share a relevant
protected characteristic and persons who
do who do not share it and Foster good
relations between persons who share such
characteristics and those who don't in
addition in advancing a qualitive
opportunity councils should remove or
minimize disadvantages suffered take
step to meet take steps to meet the
needs of disadvantaged persons and
encourage those persons to participate
in public life in making the officer
recommendation chair officers have
considered the needs of potential
occupiers of the property giving due
regard to the obligations of the act in
the public sector equality Duty and
weighed them in the planning balance
along with the general amenity of the
area officers have concluded that the
impact on the wider community of The
Proposal outweighs any adverse impact on
those with those protected characteris
SS I've prepared a few slides chair if
Alice is able to to move through them
just a remind of what was discussed at
yesterday's site visits the first slides
share outlines the site the center with
the three adjoining Properties or
residential units to the West Northwest
and the east Southeast thanks
Alice and the application site again
chair outlined in red you can see the
dwelling house and the associate out
buildings within the the site area the
site been accessed from the track to the
South with South Street bordering the
site to the north but with no direct
access to the site from
it the outline of the existing and the
proposed site PL CH one on the left
showing the dwelling house and the
garden as is made to the rear Garden as
sit out and the report and then the
provision of the six car parking spaces
to the
front thanks
Alice this is just a depiction of the
existing property and as is noted in the
report there are no external alterations
proposed to the property
chair and the floor plans bit small I
appreciate but the proposed floor plans
on the right show the two sorry show the
three units two on the ground floor and
one on the Upper Floor both independent
set aside from others so creating three
in effect three units of occupation
thanks
Alice and finally there just
two photos chair as a reminder of what
was discussed yesterday at at site
visits this first one is the property as
is and the second is one showing the
access to the track that then accesses
the property from um stations Station
Road thank you
chair speakers on the
application first of
which Katy Goodwin an objector there
will be they will have three minutes to
get over their points and will be
informed when 30 seconds remain as
members you can ask them to clarify any
matters that that have been raised but
remember your question should only
relate to the points of
which they already
made can ktie come forward thank
you can you
confirm that this is your name k Goodman
thank you very much and that you
understand the
process you have three minutes to
speak oh yeah thank
you do start whenever or does someone
tell
me oh okay thank you I'd like to talk
about what a private Lane means if you
haven't ever lived on one which most
people haven't you just don't get it
particularly when it's a c back there
are many positives such as much less
noise no antisocial Behavior quiet no
through traffic and less litter the only
people arriving on foot our car live
here are visiting so a stranger sticks
out as you know everyone anyone else is
trespassing and the police can be called
this means less crime as people cannot
be on the lane without being noticed no
one park on the street as the lane is
owned and maintained by residents only
people live on private Lanes so they are
private and out of the way of the hustle
and bustle of public areas we'll feel
safer because people can't see when
you're in and out this will change if
this is approved if anyone parks on the
lane it blocks the lane completely as
it's a single width dead end track away
from the main highway it's dangerous
exit into the main Highway due to the
visibility issues from Cars Parts on the
main road The Refuge L will not come up
to collect the bins they must be taken
to the main Highway delivery drivers
after reverse down the lane due to no
turning space this is a secluded Lane
with no Street lighting no Pavements and
the ground is uneven and sludgy in
winter it's dangerous for anyone
including Lodgers and carers on foot or
bicycle there's been up to six cars for
just one lodger which what would happen
if there were six lodges it would cause
obstructions with nowhere else to park
and not enough spaces on the drive an
absent landlord won't resolve issues and
visitors are not interested in
respectful parking there's already been
trespass issues with one person and
Builders we're aware it's a civil matter
so IBC highways or the police will be
uninterested parking is a problem as the
M as the main road is already crowded
and neighboring roads are also unadopted
if approved it will have a detrimental
impact to the Lane ground itself the
traffic will be intensified to one area
and there will be increased noise we
will lose our privacy and have more
trespass blocking of the lane most
people have lived here decades and have
few issues until this point and this
will be a daily occurrence we have not
objected to the other five properties
that approved to be bill in the current
housing crisis but will they go away go
their ahead with these Highway shoes we
shouldn't have to spend time asking
trespassing people to move their
vehicles and respect the lane parking
can be very emotive it has a detrimental
impact on community
cohesion there are safety concerns for
emergency services Vehicles needing
access it could be life or death we
shouldn't have increased Lane
maintenance cost due to the amount of
vehicles using it it will feel like IBC
is laying and our immunities will be
affected forever if you live on a
private Lane the positives outweigh the
negatives 30 seconds remain if this is
approved it will take away the positives
and leave leave us with more negatives
having self-built your home in a quiet
private area it is unlikely you will
ever be able to do this again anywhere
else and you shouldn't feel forced to
move due to these issues you shouldn't
have to worry about checking if the
coast is clear before you can leave your
house and fundamentally you should
always be able to access your home
safely without any problems or concerns
this is a basic human right please
refuse this
application thank you KY thank
you sorry if you could just remain in
your chair just in case members wish to
ask you any
questions yes yes members may ask
questions okay thank you good afternoon
and you know it's quite alarming what we
hear when you say the upkeep of the lane
does that actually mean that everybody
that lives on that lane has to pay for
the upkeep of it yes correct so we all
have to pay for the maintenance of the
road yeah because we own it yeah and
when was that last done uh well we all
just kind of I don't know when was when
was it last done couple of months ago
Tony yeah a couple of months ago yeah if
you don't mind me asking what did you do
to it uh we put like Stone mixed gravel
yeah fill the potholes in that sort of
stuff okay thank you thank
you hi KY um you mentioned that
currently there's one person in that
property but you mentioned six cars I
don't know if you know the answer to
this but what are the six cars that that
have been there regular uh because
reading through the report there's one
person it said two
cars have you any idea what the six cars
have been um I mean obviously there is
some assumption but we have heard that
it's been from various other
professionals so whether that be uh
people supplying like medication
additional carers um I don't know if
there's been any other other visitors
but we are assuming that it's other
professionals that have been visiting um
to obviously help with the person's care
that's needed like I say um I think
we've been made aware from people that
have heard of the things that have said
you know that the person in in this
particular instance needed some had
additional care needs so of course if
there's up to six people in there you
can imagine that six cars for one person
it absolutely may have could be up to
like 20 30 cars for people particularly
when they're just moving into the
property if they've got additional care
needs then obviously if they need to
have other um you know care professional
bodies hospital visits I don't I don't
know um but that's what we're aware
of council
ellot thank you chair do you know if
this went ahead and let's say there were
six residents in there do you know if
this has supported care externally or
whether there are living 24hour carers
should we
say
well I guess from from the application
from from a point of supported living my
understanding is that that's not 24-hour
residential care so I feel like there
might be a bit of ambiguity over what
exactly is being provided I I don't know
if there's been a from the from what's
on the report um and in the application
I wasn't under the impression that
people had any living caring facility in
there that could be wrong but if
somebody's providing 24hour care I'm
assuming that that means that they'll be
awake if there's no living space either
so sorry chair so so you don't know if
this will be someone living in 24 hours
taking care of these residents uh what
we've what we've been told is that the
care is provided on a one: one ratio um
so and that there will be 24hour care so
obviously there'll be shift changeovers
so at one point if there's if there is a
one to one care ratio and six people are
in at total that means that there at
least need 12 vehicle spaces for the
shift change over as well if everyone's
arriving by a car plus
visitors thank you thank
Youk you councilor Elliot could officers
uh answer councilor Elliot's question
please chair officers have set out in
the the report what the submitted
documentation advises and the submission
sets out that there would be individ
individual units in each of the
three I'll call them Flats but but
there's two there's three individual
independent residential units proposed
two on the ground floor one on the Upper
Floor and the submission says that one
person will lock by each of those with
up to two carers on a rolling 24hour two
shift program so no inhouse living but
carers up to two carers per person at
any one time hence the the report
setting out that that may be three
individuals in each of the units with up
to two carers at any one time that's the
way the application's framed in any case
thanks Adrian I didn't actually ask for
you to do that so through the chair um
and I didn't see that little bit in the
report so my apologies if if that
slipped my attention I just wondered U
whether that setting that was going to
be what we're what we're having
explained to whether that setting would
be 24 hours with someone on site caring
for these people if there are six and
and depending upon their needs or
behavioral needs or whatever whether
somebody's going to be in their
247 attending to them but I think you've
probably answered some of it if you know
any more then I'll quite happily accept
it through you chair I can only
reiterate what I've just said that that
the application is set out in those
terms in the submission that was that
was made and maybe there are speakers um
further down the line Who You may wish
to to ask Clarity
from thank you uh just one question
Casey uh you did mention uh antisocial
Behavior at the moment there is no
antisocial Behavior no okay thank you
very
much well as of yeah now as
in before the person moved in there was
no social behavior sorry just to clarify
Council okay yeah I'm I'm now not clear
whether this is for three residents are
six I thought I read in the application
it was three is
that we we're yeah I mean the the the
units can hold up to six people so we're
a little bit confused as well because
the the report actually mentions there's
I think there's about three different
classes that it's mentioned some say
class two some say three some say three
some say four it's very confusing for us
as well but um but yeah they take up to
six people so it might be applied for as
three but they they can take up to six
okay thank
you thank you councilor
G could the next you're pH
to thank
you okay the next objector
is Denise barisford
[Music]
three minutes is a joke I put back
commenting my life's been turned
completely upside down I'm using my
house completely differently to the way
I did originally I I need to can you
confirm your name yeah and that you
understand the process yeah
and you have three minutes starting
right my life's been turned completely
upside down I'm using my house
completely differently to the way I was
before all the work started with
Builders arriving at 6:00 a.m. in the
morning s days a
week right under my bedroom window foul
language loud music shouting doging
nothing the council can do because
planning application hasn't been
confirmed so they can't do anything to
restrict times then I the builders tell
us that they finished working on it so
the property is finished we then go out
back out in the garden because I wasn't
able to use the garden all summer went
back out in the garden on the day that I
went out someone arrived and was told
within my hearing C it was as close as I
am to you that they were moving in that
day the poor guy became very distressed
shouting screaming banging on the
vehicles that were there I ran inside I
was scared I was shaking I've worked
with people with behavioral difficulties
and with learning difficulties and I
know how difficult it is for them since
then I've heard him from in my own
bedroom with my window shut crying out
from in the garden and from outside I
don't want it I don't want to um IBC are
hurting me why will nobody listen to me
why will nobody believe me and I know
someone who wasn't listened to and
wasn't believed and then they were found
to be harmed and I find it I'm shaking
find it extremely distressing and I've
cried buckets for this guy I can't live
my life like that I could come away from
work and to my home I'm a cancer patient
and the builders laughed at me when I
tried to explain to them I should have
been resting I had to go out of my
actually go out of my house I've
completely gone off my list now what
I've got written down here um I can't
have I to come out of my bedroom which
has got an on sweet bathroom I've got
mobility issues I'm at the furthest
bedroom for my bathroom and at night
it's it's I'm giving you personal
details here but it's embarrassing
because I can't get to the toilet quick
enough but I can't live in that bedroom
next to what's happening to me and hear
it day in day out when he F when he
first arrived there was six carers on
the site at each change over that was 12
vehicles coming we have one bus service
in pilsley nobody's going to arrive on
buses and bikes like it says in the
planning application we've got one bus
service planning application been turned
down for more bus services than that my
life's completely changed already and
planning application hasn't been given
planning consent hasn't been given so
what are you going to do are you going
to PL pass pass it pass it and just
changed my life forever I've built that
house for me to go and build somewhere
else at my age now is impossible to find
somewhere on a situation where I've
lived 38 years remain I've lived there
38 years and I've never and I'm 62 and
I've never in my entire life had to live
like
this and I can't put up with any longer
I don't that's a sanctuary for me with
my care and what I need it's no longer a
sanctuary and hasn't been all summer I
can't go out in the fresh air and enjoy
my
garden my whole life has changed you're
supposed to be my my voice the council
have been impotent or incompetent I've
said in letters is it m v m v because
why would a company do all this and then
not and and you know with unless
somebody had already told them they
could go ahead and do it thank you um
I'm sorry I've gone completely off my
script I do apologize toise um can I
throw it out to members questions pleas
ask me
anything councilor
Ral sorry that you feeling this way yeah
I'm just holding back tears at a minute
right you know when you you mentioned
about IBC saying that this person you
hting me Etc did you ever report it as a
safe yes I rank Safeguard I rank
shaffield city council we were informed
was the first people that were involved
with him in darash County Council nobody
sent to be interested in it at all and I
I've said I thought it was safeguarding
issue surely they must have due
diligence I mentioned it to an IBC
worker and they said don't know it it
will all be done in place they wouldn't
would do this to the tenant it must all
be all be above board so nobody's done
looked into it because this poor guy if
this isn't pass has got to move surely
so nobody's given him a consideration as
he been used as a porn to try and get it
passed that's what's going through our
mind it's either in our mind either
something's being done completely wrong
and we're all being laughed at and
having two fingers piters or um somebody
from the council has given them in May
told him it's going to go now which
which is it we don't know I can assure
you from what yeah from what we're
seeing with her eyes we've no idea we
would not have given any information it
makes me feel like the whole planning
process is a fce and is not there for us
we are we built our houses and we follow
the planning rules to to the
letter would we the mugs yeah the
government sadly you know it's up to
them we have to follow what they yeah
well were we the mugs because we did it
as it should have been
done anybody else
now I can't believe environmental health
offerer hasn't done a better job of
because that was garbage thank you
Denise thank
you can I call the next speaker another
object LM
Bo
can you confirm that this is your name
it
is okay you have three minutes to speak
I press this do
I it's already on it's already on thank
you this is a very unusual and
contentious application for supported
living 99.9% of which is cited on public
roads and perhaps only 90 over 90% of
you in this room would agree with
supported living because we do too
however anyone who has ever lived in an
isolated house or on a secluded Lane
that's private would 100% not agree with
supported living being put on this
road not only is it secluded but it's
pitch black at night and you have to go
up the lane and meet Unknown People and
possibly men at close proximity just to
get to your home and these are possibly
men all with mental health issues that
would be very frightening particularly
for women do we even think about it it's
scary you have to live on a private Lane
to understand fully all the issues
public opinion on what gets placed on
public roads is relevant but public
opinion is not relevant on Pate private
ownership
roads it's not suitable for even The
Lodges that are going to be placed there
because three out of four of them suffer
from hate crime anyone vulnerable
elderly children and especially women
can never feel safe or be safe on an
unmade deadend road with no Escape Route
secluded pitch black at night you do not
see women on their own even on the
daytime on the five pits
Trail you would think of them very
foolish to go out there on their own in
the pitch back dark but they have a
choice whether they go on the five pits
Trail we do not we have to we have to
reach our homes and there is no other
route on private Lanes it is key that
you know who should be on that lane and
who should should not be there because
if approved there would just be too many
different faces changing all the time
and these would be people that we would
be meeting we don't know which ones have
got the unknown backgrounds which ones
with the challenging behaviors because
when you've got challenging behaviors
you can be unpredictable you can get
verbally abusive you can be aggressive
even worse you could turn violent
there's no guarantees at all and not
even with with any
conditions because they can be taken off
anywhere at appe peal environment
highways and even a policy officer have
not understand the issues his privately
Lan poses devoid of reality if this Lane
is appropriate what on Earth is
inappropriate 30 seconds remain however
the parish council MP and Polie do
recognize this it took 20 weeks for IBC
to put an application and get work done
and move some people in some of us was
waited 25 years just to get an
application approved we built our owns
to the rules in a place that we love
it's taken decades to build our safe
community and it will take just
nine signatures on a bit of paper to
destroy at all that's time
chair please refuse this application
thank you have any members any questions
about the points which the speaker has
made in a
presentation councelor Hancock thanks i'
I'd just like to clarify one thing
because I actually near me there's a
situation very very similar to this and
they don't have issues at all sorry you
I live in a I live I live in tupton
we've got we've got one that's a very
similar setup um down the cart track so
I've seen this in practice um you made
reference to the people potentially
having mental health issues it actually
says people with learning disabilities
and with autism that's a very different
dis that's a very different setup and
they're very unlikely to be violent or a
threat um well I dispute that because on
you go and N I looked it up when I
originally saw this application because
I've helped people like my like those
and we've got well Denise's out people
like those as well uh I took in a
homeless person Denise has taught autism
and and learning difficulties so I look
I was quite when I first saw it I'm
thinking oh but then I went on to yugov
and N or organization websites which are
two prominent websites and it tells you
what learning what learning difficulties
and autism and the displays the
challenging displays of behavior they
can have and that's what I've listed
there that is not me making that up no
I'm not suggesting it is I'm just
clarifying the difference between what's
been said and what you're saying that
has come off you go for people with
mental disabilities learning
difficulties and autism and all these
people you've only got to go on Health
Care websites to see the sort of people
that are helped and we ar against that
this is not about the people we love the
I I took it over as personally and I
loved him to this it was one of those
transitions he couldn't live at home and
uh he needed a year transition before he
could go out into the world at 18 you
know we had the police there very
regularly they were shouting all the
time we were stealing even stole a steak
you know and under the bed it broke in
twice when he left we didn't call the
police we loved him and he turned up two
years later and thanked us we understand
the needs of these people but we also
understand that people that are broken
and have broken lives and come from have
all sorts of things happen to them
haven't can't to always communicate what
they what they want in a way that we
would expect and it's not their fault no
but on you and you're on a pitch black
late and you're a woman and you're going
up there and you can hear aggressive
voices or anything like like that
because they can't communicate well and
they can do things very unpredictably
it's very frightening for women
particularly so so no my my query going
back to it is kind of where where your
um where your background was goinging
from because that was obviously say
stating very
different background comes from my own
experience and also looking at at length
we've done a lot of research on it what
sort of challenging behaviors these
people can display and I mean it was
interesting to us on niss or that even
with carers with them 24 hours a day um
ni or suggests that carers if they do
get violent carers should leave them
remove themselves and call the police
but I'm just wondering what happens if
somebody gets upset and violent on the
lane and we're coming down there at the
same time and they're going to run off
and call the police we don't know how to
deal with anything like
that and we shouldn't have to we we've
got to reach our homes and get back to
the highway and we have to go up this
Lane it's just it will change the area
yeah it'll change the feel of it we've
never had a problem up until now at all
but knowing who's on that lane is really
important on a private Lane because they
stick out if they if they not don't
belong there but we'd never know anymore
who would do who would be a
any other
questions councilor G uh you mentioned
the five pitch Trail yeah is there an
access from your lane then no but the
five pitch Trail is like 50 like 70
yards up the road from where we are just
an example and I'm just trying to say
that you know women do live different
lives to men we have to think where we
park as car when we on a own and we have
to come back at night and things like
that we have to we have to consider all
sorts of things and change our behaviors
you know we don't even get in lifts I
don't if I'm in a car park in the
daytime because I'm frightened that
somebody might come into the lift and I
don't know who they are and a lot of it
is not always you know you can go on the
five pits Trail and 100% or 99.9% of
those men wouldn't cause you any harm in
fact they'd protect you but it's the
thought and it stops people going so you
just using that as an example yes we've
got beautiful five pits Trail but you
don't see women on the road and you
think quite foolish if they went there
on Pitch start night on their
own well that's up to the individual I
think
paron that's up to the individual how
they conduct their lives yes but we
we're quite vulnerable on that lane okay
thank
you thank you councilor G any other
members
question thank you Miss Bo thank
you now next
speaker is also an objector Anthony
Walker
afternoon good afternoon can you confirm
that this is your name yes Anthony
Walker you understand the process I do
yeah we'll given three minutes to speak
thank you myself and my wife live
directly next daughter garden house the
property in question is a Gable wall
That's approximately 1.5 M from our
boundary fence and the gardens are
directly next to each other I'm speaking
on behalf of all the residents who live
in close vicinity to the subject of the
planning application are also concerned
about the effect it's having on us all
we strongly objected the plan proposal
on the grounds that the overdevelopment
that it brings will have an unacceptable
detrimental impact on the neighboring
properties through noise and
disturbance we as neighbors have already
experienced unacceptable unsocial levels
of disturbance caused not only by
workers arriving and leaving by car or
taxi but by the resident that is already
living at the property shouting and
screaming very disturbing noises that we
shouldn't have to listen to this already
having a detrimental effect on our
mental and physical health the national
uh the national planning policy
framework section 12 is clear that all
developments should promote healthy
inclusive and safe places and obviously
this does not this can be supported by a
precedent that has been set by Mansfield
District Council who have refused the
same type of application for that very
same reason in the original application
it is claimed that the property as
mature mature shrub boundaries this is
not true they also state that the Hedge
screen will be put in to help noise
pollution yet the AHL report states that
there is no evidence that Hedges provide
any form of noise barrier in section
5.82 of the local plan it is stated that
plans should respect the character of
the neighboring properties while SA
guarding the privacy and amenity of
neighboring properties we as direct
neighbors are worried that if this
proposal should be passed it will have a
longlasting detrimental effect on our
health and well-being whilst being
totally out of character with the
neighborhood thank
you thank you Mr
wer any members any questions on the
representation councilor
Cooper thanks chair thank you um the
noises that you you heard then over the
last six weeks would that be roughly
something like that how often how
frequent just do apparently from what we
can the only thing we can see is a
trampoline in the back Garden of this
particular place and the the the per the
person who's in there it must just lay
on it because I'm not see him bouncing
up down anything but we've been sat out
on our back Garden during the nice
weather enjoying nice meal in the
evening and he'll start screaming and
shouting uh IBC being horrible to me and
why is nobody listening to me and we
don't want to have to listen to that now
bearing in mind that's only when there's
one person in if there's three people
four people five people in with the same
with the same issues then we're going to
have to listen to that all the time and
it's just not
fair thank you councilor
Cooper any members any more
questions
you thank you Mr
Walker our next speaker is Adele
Ricket
who's
the can
you thank you okay can you confirm that
this is your name yeah
and that you understand the process yes
then you have three minutes to speak
thank you so uh firstly I'd just like to
introduce um IBC healthare so IBC
Healthcare is a specialist Midlands
provider who feel passionately about
individuals having a house that they can
call a home with access to specialist
speak spoke accommodation and support
packages centered around their needs no
matter how complex their needs may be so
we Empower people to live as
independently as possible free from any
unnecessary Hospital ization or
intuitional iation and that's in line
with the transforming care agenda which
is part of the NHS guidance to support
Commissioners to reduce the number of
people with a learn disability Andor
autism residing in hospital or secure
impatient settings so as most of you may
know from um recent media retention um
the the program focus is to identify and
develop Community
alternatives to um impatient settings in
line with the national service model and
it's the top of the government's agenda
um as we know most Hospital places are
now uh closing due to this reason and
people are encouraged to live in smaller
residential settings so the transforming
CARE program was first introduced back
in um 2011 following the winterborn view
Scandal um and targets to reduce the
number of people in hospital um were set
for
2014 um sadly this nearly 10 years years
later this has uh been missed year on
year with many people over 2,000 still
residing in hospital and that's largely
due to the uh lack of suitable
accommodation within the community so
the government have made a pledge this
year to ensure that there was more
connective working across um NHS England
and in line with the national plan for
both adults and children and that
brought about the um New integrated care
board so that's the drive that they're
focusing on um Station Road is a
proposed scheme that's been identified
in partnership with the surrounding
local authorities and integrated care
boards and with the
NHS um it's been identified for a number
of reasons and it will support people
within the area who are waiting
discharge from hospital or moving on
from children's um settings um IBC
conducted a thorough search for suitable
properties before finding Station Road
alongside key commissioning contact
and our robust search criteria consisted
of detached properties private driver
restricted views um and not in close
contact with um neighbors um it's widely
recognized that most autistic people
with a learn disability and autism being
in an impatient setting is very deeply
damaging um as we've all seen from most
Panorama investigations noisy
unpredictable places these apartments
have been designed in line with people's
and support needs um and in line with
the therapeutic support
model right thank you
uh have members any questions about
points which speaker has made in the
presentations councilor Hancock uh I
have two chair if you're willing for me
to ask both yeah um I mean the the first
one kind of ties in with what previous
speakers have been said and obviously
familiar well very familiar with with
people with Autism yeah it doesn't seem
appropriate to have someone in there
while building work is going to go off
because even if they're the most sedate
person on earth that is going to make
them flare up yeah so to me that seems
foolish and I'm wondering why that's
happened okay so we made that decision
not just IBC Healthcare but the court of
protection so that application did go to
the court with everything presented to
them um also the integrated care board
and the commissioning contacts within
there that are all um this was a looked
after child um he would have been
homeless or would have ended up in a
hospital setting um so both um
applications were presented to the court
and the court made the decision for him
to live at Station Road within his best
interest as he lacked capacity um
obviously we've made the home habitable
for him um and it's a single occupant
occupation at the moment there will be
um some um building Works within that
mainly St walls Etc but we'll plan that
around you know say a holiday or
whatever is in his best interest to do
at that time um but the social worker
and the um Community nurse felt that it
was in his best interest because the
alternative would have been long stay
Hospital right and and the other
question um now obviously a lot of what
we've got in here a lot of what's been
said by people and that's on the portal
yeah um comes down to a fear and a lack
of of being made aware um and it's it's
clear from comments actually in the
report that there hasn't been the
dialogue between yourselves and the
immediate neighbors that really probably
would have made this a heck of a lot
easier had that happened and perhaps you
would have even layed concerns so again
I'm wondering why that's not taken place
because in a situation like this which
is very sensitive yeah that's vital yeah
okay so Excuse Me Miss Ricker could you
speak more directly into the mic okay so
um so firstly um the Adrian took over
the um application quite late on in the
stage is before that it was a private
consultant Lynn Eastwood the objections
weren't put on the planning portal until
um the day that it closed therefore we
weren't aware that there was any
objections on the application until the
day that it was closing we weren't aware
that there were any neighbor um concerns
um sometimes we do smaller schemes and
we've had no neighbor objections and
these have gone through with no concerns
whatsoever and we've had really positive
relationships with the neighbors this is
the first time that we've encountered
any issues um the moment that the um
objections came online we were um in
dialogue through the consultation
process so we were going back and forth
with Lynn and then over to Adrian
answering queries that were coming in
and subsequently we held a meeting at
the um Community um Hall um to address
any
concerns coun
Cooper thank you
um on a similar vein
um C Lang just ask you about that public
consultation I mean it's it's good
practice from the start you knew the
issue you knew the lane you knew the
people it was a small number of people I
don't want to over egg this but you
found out the
information and this is a bit that
concerns me you arranged with residents
to meet
them but it was only residents as I
understand and we did also send an
invite through to um the parish
council's invo to the the admin to the
clerk as well
okay um I can't say that happened or
didn't happen now on that I saw that
invite and it was from 4:30 to
7:30 I arrived at
7 and the and the hall was closed now
that didn't me leave a good impression
on myself but the thing that did concern
me the most was the fact
that a number of weeks before that
meeting took place you would put
somebody in that property that's a bit
and that's the bit I don't understand
can you elaborate on that at all anymore
because that that really confuses me and
why that meeting closed and I don't know
what time it closed and I don't know how
many people went because
obviously it beat me before I could get
there yeah so obviously the majority of
residents came we all made the decision
I think it probably we probably
literally just missed you because we
finished around about uh 7 o'cl and we'd
engaged with residents it was quite a a
Tous night as you can imagine so um we
we be we moved on from there but um yeah
we l must have literally just missed you
because the caretaker was there as well
closing up at the scene
time thank you Council coob any members
Council yeah I've got two questions
first of all why have you moved him this
this man in before planning approval um
so we engaged with both the planning
enforcement officer to check that it
wouldn't be a breach of planning
regulation given the urgency of the
situation that he would have been
homeless or in a prolonged Hospital stay
they were engaging with us to say that
the the process in which we were
following was um legally binded and that
there was no concerns with moving him
into the property we also checked with
um the Care Quality commission who were
happy with this decision as well so we
took everybody's professional opinion
and everybody and it was made in the
best interest of the individual thank
you and also how do you feel when
somebody tells you that it sounds like
somebody is crying out and and either in
pain or frightened or possibly being
hurt how do you feel about that so we
are aware of this situation it did
happen u a couple of weeks after we
moved this is a known Behavior so we
have um a weekly MDT meeting with
everybody involved in his care and
support this psychiatrist the nurses
everybody the PBS um Team The Crisis
Intervention team everybody is involved
in this this is a known Behavior this
gentleman has not had a very easy start
in life um it's the way that he will um
present if he's feeling um he he'll push
people away in a situation where he
doesn't feel that he's worthy of having
something that's good in his life and
that is a known behavior um that we are
aware of and that um the the recent
feedback from his MDT meeting uh the two
weeks ago was this is the most settled
place he ever had um he just hasn't had
a very good start in life and we have
been made aware of the safeg garden that
came in that was fully investigated um
and there was no action that was
required any further both from
professionals and internally at IBC as
well
okay thank you Council councelor
Cooper thank you chair um there's been a
little bit of confusion here today um I
mean should this application be passed
I'm a bit
confused is it three people or is it or
is it six people three people is that
the intention moving forward for three
yeah or for more than three no there'll
only ever be three in there so people
will have their own that people will
have an individual tency agreement
three people okay thank
you thank you Council cop any members
questions Council
peton looking at the plans you and the
proposition your carers for nighttime
are coming in at 8:00 at night and
leaving at 9:00 in the morning have you
got any provision at all for them to sit
or do anything through the night so
there will be supporting the individuals
in their Apartments so they'll be
utilize a bit like if you had care in
your own home it's to try and create a
homely feel so in line with um CQC
regulation of building the right support
it's the staff remain with the
individual at all all the
time thank you councelor
Peterson councelor
Rous afternoon I'm a little bit confused
because on your speech you you referred
to at one point a child and then turned
it around to an adult so what age is
this
person
so um we support people from 18 plus and
what I was elaborating with was they
transform Arts from birth to to end of
life and that is for both children and
adults what we tend to do is engage um
with the local Authority or the NHS
early on so when somebody says 16 and
we'll work with a a trajectory of how we
support them into adulthood because we
know that transition can be quite
difficult for individuals so that's what
I was elaborating to that we'll work
with the M on but we support them from
18 plus okay thank
you any members thank you Mr thank
you our next
speaker is Jennifer Hughes who's the
agent can you confirm this is your name
and that you understand the
process
go you have three minutes to speak okay
right so um two key issues uh began this
application process on less than an idal
footing um in our opinion firstly the
confusion that existed with regards to
the site notice and the timing and
location of its placement on the site um
and secondly the delayed uploading of
objections onto the planning website um
the combined effect of these events
understandably created great concern and
distrust from the local residents
um that their views were not being heard
or considered it also led to delayed
engagement by the applicant uh that
further sort of Amplified the
situation um in response to the
objections and the consultation comments
the applicant submitted numerous very
detailed supplementary information
documents that you will have seen and
ultimately there was a public
consultation event so I think we we did
engage with trying to speak with to
respond to Residents it just wasn't via
a public consultation it was via
numerous supplementary information
documents um this resulted in um
basically the local authorities you know
the environmental health officer the
highways officer and the policy officer
finding no reason to object to the
scheme um and highlighting that the
local plan policy lc4 specifically
encourages support of the provision of
specialist housing in appropriate
locations when considering um neighbor
amenity which I know has is obviously
you know a key area I would like to
stress here the importance of the
comparison between the proposal um and
the existing seven-bedroom property that
exists on the site at the moment um any
new neighbors moving into a property of
this size have the potential to create a
higher level of noise and disturbance
than the previous owners as for example
multiple children can scream and cry
indiscriminately and a large family of
teenagers and adults would have multiple
cars and
vehicles as with all um similar
proposals the engagement of the adult
care commissioning team at darash
Council and the Darby and dar NHS
integrated care board was needed from a
very early stage as my colleague has
just said um their expert opinion that
the property and proposals were suitable
was given to IBC Healthcare and the
application would not have been
submitted without that although um
requested via the consultation process
comment from these parties unfortunately
was not able to be given due to local
Authority departmental
policies the mppf is clear that
development should promote healthy
inclusive and safe places um attention
has it seems so far been drawn to the
safe requirement of the
mppf the risk assessments and the
management 30 seconds remain described
in the supplementary documents
illustrate that safety issues are far
from inedible and even the possibility
of them has been limited to acceptable
levels the inclusivity requirement of
the mpaf should also be assessed or it
raises the question as to whether
gentrified areas are exempt from
inclusivity given the and type of the
existing property the local plan and
mppf policy compliance the consult te
support and the expert advice and
support of the adult care commiss it is
clear that the balance leans towards
approval your time is up um me Members
would you any
questions okay thank you very
much not turned up
okay right colleagues we will now move
to questions to the officers as always I
would like to keep this part of our
proceedings focused on getting clarity
about any points you are not sure of
once we have done this we can then have
our discussion about the application
based on what we've heard and read
councilor yeah can I can I ask Adrian to
confirm what Adell Ricket said
about the enforcement officer being
asked about moving this man into the
house
please sorry sorry um I just asked if um
it could confirm what Adele Ricket said
about the enforcement officer saying it
was okay to move this man in before
planning permission was granted thank
you I wasn't involved in that
conversation chair so I can't confirm or
deny what we said I'm afraid what is
normal practice though is that as has
been determined both by individual
councils and the courts that where there
is a process in place to reach a
determination on a on an issue in this
case a planning
application proper course
of action is not
to affect that outcome until it's
instance to stop an activity or use or
development ahead of that planning
application being certainly contrary to
officer advice it's the advice is to
allow that process to continue and be
concluded so that a decision as in a
decision this afternoon should be taken
on the application if the application
were approved obviously development
could carry on if not then the council
would need to determine what action
should be taken then so I
can't confirm or deny what was said in
any conversation I wasn't party to that
I'm afraid but the proper and du
processes to allow the determination of
the application to take place without
seeking to to undertake action ahead of
that unless it was so bad that that
something um should be done but the
proper process has been taken and I'm
sure the advice from from my colleague
was the correct one he's is's a very
experienced and eligible officer I'm
sure the advice he gave was
correct councelor thank you sorry Adrian
here we go um the the different
categories of um resident
residents um can you tell us about that
because we seem to be categorically told
there's only going to be three in but
I'm reading when I've read all this
report that potentially can be six and
it once once or or if we ever P this
they can please theel how they how they
determine who they put in what what kind
of person goes
in I'm I'm a little more worried about
we seem to be talking about the health
care of of individuals rather than the
physical application it all seems to be
based around the individual's needs you
know I don't understand who's going in
whether they need social
care 24hour care whether they need cams
cams teams in or have no idea I'm really
you know and I really don't understand
that where where where that comes into
the application uh the bit I wanted to
ask you about was actually in the part
of this report where it says the police
report makes clear it's yet to be
settled in planning law as to whether
the behavior of residents can be a
material planning decision or
consideration can you can you tell us a
bit about that if if well I I'll come to
that in in a second I just try and
address the first point as far as I
understand it first of all the
application seeks consent to change a
single residential unit I the Dormer
Bungalow that exists on the site from
that I a single unit of accommodation to
three individual units of accommodation
so in effect as the applicants have set
out they would seek the council's
approval for the change of use of that
dwelling house to three I'm I'm calling
them Flats but there's two units on the
ground floor and one on the Upper Floor
so if you took all it's a noral bungle
at the moment and the applicants are
seeking consent to change that to three
independent residential units I'm
calling them Flats but they're not all
stack on top of one another two are on
the ground floor and one's on the top so
that's if you strip everything else away
that's what you're being asked to
consider so if you want to take
everything else out of it the issue
before you this afternoon could be that
you be being asked for consent to
convert a single unit into three
residential
units and the application you'll be
considering later on the this afternoon
something similar
actually the issue around that then is
that in the applicant
submissions and as you've heard this
afternoon from
um Adele the intention is to place
within each of these units a single
person but being provided with as far as
I understand the submitted details
24-hour rolling Care on two shifts and
again the information that we have is
that will be provided on up to two
carers per individual at any one time so
as officers we've taken that on its face
so we've gone One Step Beyond one unit
into three units we've taken that on its
face without making any judgment on what
use class that would fall into and and
the applicants view is set out in the
report they think it stays in a class C3
dwelling house use others have made a
different view officers
haven't concluded on that we've just
taken the application on its face that
the application is seeking consent for
three individual single units of
accommodation Flats as I call them but
with this ongoing 24-hour potentially
24-hour rolling care and the view that
we've taken as officers on that is that
is a use and activity that is in terms
of its character one that isn't
compatible with the with the general
character of the area and that's that's
the conclusion that officers have come
to and members will will need to take a
view whether you agree with that
summation or not whether you think that
intensification in the use of the
property from three sorry from one to
three and all that comes with it with or
without the care is something that you
accept or not if permission is granted I
unless you were to put a planning
condition on any approval that only one
person would be full-time resident at
any one of those units at any time and
you could place such a condition on if
you wish if that was if that was the
Tipping Point for you then without that
condition we couldn't control the number
of units who would live in each of those
units because in effect you would given
permission for three residential units
you could have a family of four living
in each or a family of one or but you
are saying then that that for each
individual person in each unit will be
two care
so nine adults permanently on S at all
time again as officers we've just taken
the the application on its merits that's
the information that's been put to us
that each individual would have up to
two carers at any one time but I'm I'm
not going to be able to sit here this
afternoon and say say to you as you
you've heard this
afternoon specialist to go there I'm
afraid um may know more about this but
I'm not a specialist I'm afraid in in um
assisting people with Autism
or
um needs if you like apologize for the
the clunkiness of my language um
but but I'm just but but that's the the
basis on which the application's been
made in terms just of the The Wider
issues about
the the people who will live here and
their individual um activities
as as officers we've taken the
environmental health officer advice on
its on its face in that with the noise
mitigation plan which is is is fairly
generalized but with ongoing supervision
outside the property officers are of the
view that if that's
provided that would be sufficient
mitigation that's our conclusion on that
issue in terms of the the the variety of
other issues that you you've heard of
this afternoon so we've not placed
weight on that issue itself again you'll
need to take a view as to whether you
you agree with that or not and and and
just finally um on on the issue of the
the comments of the police we we
acknowledge those and in terms of the
conclusion on the use as I say officers
haven't concluded on that in the report
we've not taken a view on that because
as I say permissions in effect on its
face is being sought for three
individual Flats I'm calling the
flats if the use class for Residential
Properties is and the use of res as a
dwelling house by a single person or
people living together as a family the
class C2 use which is a different use
class is used for the provision of a
residential accommodation and care to
people in need of care and I think it
would be a planning judgment whether
three Flats with ongoing 24-hour rolling
care of up to two carers Falls within
one or other class but officers haven't
gone to that point we have come to the
conclusion that the level of activity
asset out on the face of the application
has led us to our conclusion and you
will need to consider that just finally
if I may and casell didn't raise this so
I apologize but you've heard a lot this
afternoon again about other issues
comings and goings bin collection and
and Highway Safety officers are very
clear in our view on that that we don't
believe there is evidence that even at
intensified use of of three residential
units as opposed to one that that would
be an overriding
Factor thanks
chair Council
coper thanks counc you
just one of them yes at least uh I just
wanted to clarify Adrien because this
application's been in the mix for a
considerable time um and we've just
heard um M Ricket say about the the uh
the uploading of the objection
can you just clarify for me when when
they were actually visible to the
applicant um because I I don't know the
answer to that I can't I'm afraid chair
I don't have that information to
hand the um
I if if if they weren't uploaded in a
timely fashion I can only apologize to
to you as members that wasn't the case
but I don't know exactly when they were
as far as I'm aware all the comments
that we have even those we've received
yesterday evening are now um either
uploaded or in the process of being
uploaded so we have tried as we can to
to provide all the information to all
the parties but again my my advice to
members would be I don't think that
needs to be an overriding consideration
in the determination of the application
on on its face before you this
afternoon okay I almost just ask or
remind speakers that having um spoken
and answered questions from Members you
cannot participate further from this
point Thank
you thank you Alan any more questions
from
Members
okay right thank you thank you to the
officers for that that leads us to our
final part of the process our discussion
about what we heard and what we think
and what we decide but before going any
further I would just like to the Clark
to remind us of about
motions yes thank you
chair please bear in mind Meers that a
mo motion must be moved and seconded
before the vote is taken if an amendment
to a motion is moved and seconded then
that Amendment will be voted on first
if a motion is to be moved which goes
against officer's
recommendations then the member who has
moved the motion must give the reasons
for doing
so the reason for moving a motion
against officer recommendations should
comprise the relevant planning issues
and be supported by evidence as
necessary if a motion to reject officer
recommendations Falls or in other words
it is not passed that doesn't mean that
the recommendations are automatically
approved rather you will need to take a
positive decision through a further
Motion in favor of the
recommendations or a different course of
action this will need to be approved by
the committee through another vote thank
you
chair I would now like to open the floor
for a
debate
if there's no debate here then I think
actually U members may wish to uh go
straight to the um suggestions of
motions on
now could I go and recommend that we go
with the officer's recommendation to
refuse his planning
permission councilor
Cooper
sorry um yeah I I'll second that motion
and for the reasons set out in the
report and also the fact that it the
change would be very detrimental in my
opinion to that area of the village
which is literally a lane that goes
nowhere it's quiet it's dark and for all
the reasons set out then I'll second
that
thank you you Council
Co chair if I may just before you you go
to to any v as AR just like to to ask um
if those particular if members are happy
with the reason for ause set out in the
report or do you want anything further
adding to that in view of the comments
that councilor Cooper has made
chair
right members we have a motion
before no we've done that so shall I uh
just um move now to the vote sh and take
the roll call yes please
Alam okay thank you
members councelor Chum
for councelor
Cooper councelor
Elliot councelor G
four councelor
Hancock
four councelor Lacy
four councelor liot
for councelor Peterson
for and councelor
Rouse uh that's unanimous chair the
motion has
passed
any speakers that want to leave may
leave
we're moving on to the second
application item five
any thank you yes I think that's legis
mature
right we'll move on to the second
application item 5
n23
49 oh
apologize thank you now that we can move
on to second
application going to ask the planning
officers to tell us about any late
comments and give us a brief
presentation showing any photos and
plans to the site I will allow the
officers to complete their presentation
consequently members unless they have
the point of a point of order you you
feel cannot wait you should please
reserve these for any questions about
the process Until the
End Adrian oh it's
Alice thank you chair I haven't had any
other late representations apart from
the one that is included in the late
representations document um of which I
already commented on but if there's any
questions about that we can deal with
that at the end um this is an
application for the change of use of a
commercial unit with ancillary
accommodation above to one office and
three one bed Flats at 67 rupit Street
lower pilsley
the application site is to the west of
ret Street and is here shown in
Orange and this shows it a little bit
closer in and here is the red line of
the site the building is part of a ro
building to west of rupit Street there
is on street parking available at this
point although the building has not been
occupied for some time the extant
planning use is a mixture of classy
commercial on the ground floor with a
three-bedroom flat
above the proposal seeks to reduce the
area in The Classy use by about 25% so
that the front part of the ground floor
will remain as a shop or office and the
rear becomes the ground floor of one of
the residential Flats officers are of
the view that this loss of social
infrastructure is outweighed by the
benefits of the renovations to the
building and bringing it back into use
particularly as the remainder of the
ground floor will remain in class E
use remainder of the building will be
converted to three self-contained
one-bedroom Flats table at paragraph 26
of the report shows that these Flats
will meet the National Space standards
for two two bed two person Flats the
green and purple uh yeah the green and
purple ones colored in on this drawing
and one one bed one person flat which is
in
Blue uh parking and turning for two
vehicles is proposed to the rear as is a
small shared Garden area for use by
residents of the flats the Garden area
does not meet the requirements for
successful places of 25 met square
meters per flat however due to the
Village location and the proximity
public open spaces offices are of the
view that the lack of private imunity
space is not so harmful as to make the
proposal
unacceptable changes to the exterior of
the building including the removal of
Shutters on the access to the G to the
rear Garden changes to the windows on
the front
elevation following our section of
photos which was seen at yesterday's
site
visit this Photograph was taken earlier
this year when the application first was
submitted and this one was taken not Soo
long ago um and since then the shutters
have been removed from the front windows
the applicant proposes to reinstate the
central door and remove the shutter over
the
access the only changes proposed to the
rear of the building is the removal of
the French window on the first floor to
be replaced by window with no access
onto the flat roof vehicle access to the
rear is existing and as such highways
are of the view that whilst is
substandard the proposal does not
represent an intensification of the use
and therefore the impact on highway
safety would not be
severe the building has an extent use as
a shop or office with three bedroom flat
above this comes with Associated parking
of vehicles and comings and goings
offices are of the view that the
proposal for a shop office with three
one bedroom Flats would not represent
such an intensification of the use as to
result in severe harm to the highway
safety furthermore it's considered that
the renovation of the building will
benefit the character and appearance of
the area and as the consequence officers
are recommending that this application
be approved thank you
[Music]
chair on the application they are Peter
Kemp the applicant will have three
minutes to get over his point and they
will be informed when 30 seconds
remain you can ask him to clarify any
matters that have been
raised but remember your question should
only relate to the points which have
already been
made thank you Peter can you confirm
your name I can yes and you understand
the process yes I do you have three
minutes to speak okay thank you uh so a
few things I just want to bring to your
attention through the public
consultation uh there was only one uh
objection one neighbor for objection um
it who lives two minutes walk from the
front of the shop his objection was the
parking which I believe has been
addressed by the officers and the
highways um there's also only me here
today to give evidence there's nobody
here who feels strongly enough to object
to uh the scheme I'm looking forward to
you know bringing this property back
into public use creating three
one-bedroom Flats which are well needed
in the area uh Flats now I mean all
properties that come up for rent they're
getting about 20 applicants per uh per
vacancy so you know you can't deny that
this is a a much needed addition there
has been some talk about antisocial
behavior um I don't really think that's
relevant you can't really say it's going
to create antisocial Behavior just
because of the type of dwelling that it
is so I'm hoping that you can put it
forward for AAL straight away thank
you thank you Mr
K
right
questions questions from
Members questions to
officers K you can now go back to your
seat
[Music]
thanks colleagues we have an opportunity
to put questions to the officers about
the
application
coun Cel earlier thank you chair for
looking up um yeah just the question of
how was the parking addressed because I
read that the it was originally for far
five five units and into the roof space
and so on it has been lessened so how
have we made the parking
work so um the building as it is um
could be currently used as a shop um
with its Associated coming and going and
parking and a three-bedroom uh house um
we don't have um formal guidance on
parking but um the County Council
suggests that a three bedom house would
usually generate um two parking spaces
two cars um so and a one bedroom flat
would have one so we're talking about a
net increase of one
car um added to that um although there
is vehicle access around the back I'm
not convinced that that has actually
been used forly as parking before but
this applic actually does include two
formal parking spaces at the rear um
so in my view the the change that this
proposes to parking is is negligible
compared to what it could be used for
right now with no no need for a change
of planning permission or no no planning
permission Council liot thank you I'm
just a bit concerned about the your
Wildlife bat survey is issue because
apparently on the 22nd of September they
said they you needed a bat survey since
then they' said they're not building in
the roof so you don't need a bat survey
and also it says they're not um changing
the changing the roof but on figure five
it says concrete roof tiles as though
there is going to be a new
roof so I have S clarification from um
from the applicant and there is no plan
to do any work to the roof that
including there's no re Roofing planned
so uh I do recognize that uh Dar
Wildlife just um in their last comment
to us said that they felt that it's
still required a b survey but we are of
the view that since nothing is happening
to the roof that doesn't doesn't apply I
did ask for them for you know I went
back to them but they haven't got back
to me unfortunately um so but I think I
think we we can be confident that it
doesn't require a about
survey Al
Cooper thank you chair um Alice I mean I
live in the
village I know what parking's like and I
do believe that this will cause a bit of
an issue can you just can we just go to
one of the one of the slides where it
shows you the rear where they're going
to actually make
the
to
space because I'm not with the back of
that building
um currently can't get to
it so um that's taken from about the
middle of the garden
um there So the plan is is so you can't
it's not great because you can't see all
of it but the the parking will be at the
end of that brick buil building there if
we go back to the
um
plan you can see sorry it's not very big
is it but there's there's space for two
cars to park and then there's a little a
small immunity area at the at the end
and then there's also space for the cars
to turn so they can leave and afford
gear is the intention for the brick
building to stay or to go because it
looks very tight it looks very tight to
me and and I acknowledged it in the
conditions that until that's in
there then this this can't be
used yeah so the the Brit built building
is intended to stay that's going to be
uh like a bicycle store storage for the
flats um you can't really see on the
screen but this does show like a SWAT
path so it shows that there's space for
the cars to turn reverse and then go
out
um yeah so I'm offices and the highways
are of the view that that this is
acceptable okay thanks
Alice any further questions for the
officers
okay thank you the officers for that
that leads us to the final part of the
process our discussion about what we
heard what we think and what we what we
want to decide I would like to go to the
floor for
debate thank you chair I think it's a a
great use of of what potentially is just
going to be another deric building I
think they've made the best of the space
at the back to park the cars I don't
think that'll be too much of an issue so
personally I will support it I I'll move
I'll move the motion when you're
ready Hancock chair I agree with coun Al
I'm happy to Second it for him to be
perfectly honest
in terms of the antisocial Behavior a
building that's left abandoned is going
to ATT trct far more than than actually
having residents in it so to me it's a
no-brainer okay right members we have a
motion before
us before we move to the vote I would
like the Clark to read it out okay chair
I think um from Mark GA then that
councelor Elliot and councelor Hancock
have moved in seconded a motion to
approve officer recommendation s which
is effectively to approve the
application is that right
members sub to the conditions are set
out in the
report chair just just from um if if you
feel as though that's important then we
we can attach a condition but just
wanted to make make it clear as officers
we don't believe there would be any
adverse impact on any protected species
for the reasons that Dallas has set out
there is a there is a note to remind the
applicant a note proposed to remind the
applicant of responsibilities if if if
they do find any at any point
but if you'd like a b box sh um then
then we would need to we would need to
condition it that's the
only
okay so then chair on that basis um I'll
um do the roll call councelor cheesum
Four councelor
Cooper Council
Elliot councelor
G four councelor Hancock for councelor
Lacy four councelor liot
four coun councelor Peterson for and
councelor
Rouse that's unanimous chair the
motion's
passed
okay
y we now have have our third piece of
business the tree preservation
order
I planning to
speak thank you chair
um
thank you um tree preservation order 293
was made in its provisional form on
5ifth June
2023 and the effect of that is the order
applies for six months or until
confirmed or modified um before deciding
to confirm an order the local Authority
must take into account all duly made
objections and representations that have
not been
withdrawn uh two objections have been
received and one letter of support from
neighboring residents has been received
and the tree officer has undertaken a
close inspection of the trees and
recommends that four trees at Clifton
Court are Merit worthy of the special
protection afforded by CPO uh one tree
described as T1 within the reports is
contested by the objection received by
the aricultural consultant instructed to
provide written
representation of the letter of support
the tree officer has recommended to not
include a number of mature trees within
the protection of TPO 293 it was the
hope of neighboring residents of Clifton
court that more trees would have been
included within the TPO protection the
officer recommendation is to confirm TPO
293 subject to
modification um and then the prepared
slides um the figure you see on the
screen the figure two within the report
describes the proposed modifications to
TPO 293 uh and the location and position
of the four
trees next
slide
there figure three within the report
shows trees one and two both beach trees
when viewed from northern common When
approaching Clifton Court from the
south the next
slide this is figure four describes
trees three and four these both lime
trees and located in the rear Garden of
Clifton Court both these trees can be
seen from the foot path to the north of
Clifton
Court
thank
you back right colleagues you will now
have the opportunity put qu questions to
the officers about it again I would like
to keep this part of the proceedings
focused on getting
clarity about any
points you are not
sure so I would be grateful if you could
move any motions at this
stage
so I think the chairman not move any
motions at this
chair question just on um page 44 it
says that um two objections have been
received and on page 49 it says
that
represent it implies there one objection
on page 49 but it looks like two
objections on page
44 can I find that point
please yeah absolutely the the
provisional order was served as an
are classification
which effectively was served as an
interim Ria to detect all the trees on
the site because there was a report of
tree felling which wasn't specific on
which trees were going to be fell
um so the area order protects everything
and the recommendation is to modify it
to include only those trees which were
Merit worthy the original objection or
the original two objections included a
number of trees but they have not been
brought forward for protection if that
makes
sense so of the the trees brought
forward to be protected only one
objection is received about that yeah
okay
any other
members
questions thank you to the officers for
that this leads us to the final part of
the process of our discussion about what
we've heard and what we think and what
we want to decide about confirming the
TPO I would like to open the floor for
debate
councelor Chason just say um I'm I'm
reasonably supportive of this and I'd be
happy for it to to
proceed have you got a second sorry I
didn't move some motions just at a
debate stage
sorry unless there is any debate shair
then um perhaps this actually is the
time to move to the motions and that is
moved in that case I'll move it CH the
officers recommendations
right we'll now ask you to vote as
explained earlier we will do this by
roll through roll call okay thanks chair
um well the motion is to approve the um
modified order as I just discussed uh
councelor Chum four councelor
Cooper councelor
ellias councelor G for counc Hancock for
councelor Lacy for councelor liot for
councelor Peterson four and councelor
Rouse that's unanimous chair the
motion's
passed
I now call on the planning officers to
explain our next report item eight
appeals lodged and
determined quiet month for appeals being
received chair as you can see we've
received no we have actually receive one
decision but since the preparation of
the report CH that will be reported next
time round so just the two appeals
lodged you'll note actually that they
both relate to specialisms within the
the council and in respect of trees and
Heritage assets so and we're very
pleased that we've got the necessary
expertise in house now to support those
appeals and present the case on behalf
of the council but nothing else to
report ch um happy to take any
questions just I just wonder if you'd
heard anything about the speed uh appeal
CH short answer through you chair is
no thank you
sorry thank thank you members do we
agree to note the
report
uh thank you as we have no urgent
business at this time we will move
straight on to item 10 the exclusion to
the
public no public here on move on no
chair um we need to actually uh move
this uh and members to formally agree it
at that point that the stream will then
end so uh could I ask you to just read
out the exclusion paragraph
there I move the public be excluded from
the meeting during the discussion of the
following item business to avoid the
disclosure to them exempt
information as defined in paragraphs 35
part one of schedule 12a the Local
Government Act
1972 as amended by local government
access to information variation order
2008 we're all
happy that then let's move on to item
11 right if members are content with
that um Martin can you confirm that the
stream has now
ended